i hear these
to me horror stories from friends that
have gotten themselves in north of a
hundred thousand dollars in debt from
their education
is it a good idea to turn your passion
into a business
oh i i think
i think if you are starting a business
that is not your passion
that's a mistake your your
business must be something you're
passionate about
is it
uh
distributing
documentaries is it a a new
streaming service is it a type of
chocolate i mean whatever it is if you
i don't think a business can succeed
unless you're passionate about what it
is and i think it's important to have
that
mission statement in your head i mean
i'm constantly altering it for film
threat but yeah i don't know how you
could even be successful in a business
that you're not passionate about but i
also think it's important to be sober
minded
if you were passionate about crochet
toilet paper holders and there's not a
market for that
it might fail
i'm talking about hand crocheted
toilet paper holders
that may be the greatest business idea
ever i'm going to guess it isn't
but um
i i just
you know whatever it is that you're
passionate about i think i i i just
don't see how you could succeed from a
business standpoint because there's so
much sacrifice
involved in business it is
um
you know and for my friends that have
very traditional jobs i have friends
that have nine to five jobs they don't
understand that i'm never not working
you know if it's 9 p.m on a saturday
night and my website goes down i have to
be available to be able to solve that
problem
right
so
and i have to be passionate enough about
it that it's not an interruption it's
something that i'm
leaping to
to take care of it right um but i do
think it's also about a balance there is
freedom in having your own business
because i can decide well this morning
i'm you know it's 11 in the afternoon
i'm gonna go see a movie and i can do
that
um it's also part of my job sometimes
but yeah i really feel like if you don't
have that passion then don't do that as
as a job
really because once you do it it doesn't
even feel like work i mean my job
doesn't i never even describe it as work
you know it's just
it's my purpose for being here
when that teacher said to you don't you
want the nine to five job i'm sorry that
was high school that was high school
yeah okay and did they send a note home
to say you know dear mrs gore by the way
your son no
no i didn't we're worried about him i
didn't get pushback from that but i do
feel
i feel betrayed by my high school
education from this standpoint
i it was very much focused on just
making good workers for certain types of
jobs and i don't know if traditional
pathways for education are preparing um
preparing young people for for the types
of jobs that are out there
um i feel in a way it might it might be
easier to just start your own job i mean
my pathway
which is very non-traditional and i'm
not recommending this i'm just telling
you as an example here's what i did
i felt somewhat betrayed by my high
school education in the sense that i
took i was like
got very good grades in school a's and
b's
3.5 3.6 plus gpa average it's um
uh
i did well
um
but i
sort of stepped outside my comfort zone
said i want to be a writer i better
learn to type so i took a typing class
and i did not get a good grade in typing
i got a c
and i got a c because i didn't type fast
enough and i thought the criteria was
wait a sec i care about accuracy you
know so i mean now i type fairly fast
but you know um
at the time i thought well why am i
being knocked out like i'm actually
that's like outside of the required
curriculum i also took a whole met class
because i wanted to cook
right and i will say this
um just in the days where i was single
and i cooked
it was as if i did a magic trick
i do think that developing skills that
are useful in life are really important
and i meet too many of my friends who
don't have
skills and i feel like
a lot of the skills that i developed in
high school and beyond were skills that
were either things that i chose to do
and maybe didn't succeed as well or they
were recreational for example when i was
in college i read a book on marketing
called marketing warfare that taught me
almost everything i needed to know about
marketing brilliant
um
it it basically this book marketing
warfare which is an updated version
um
taught me about the rivalries between
coke and pepsi mcdonald's and burger
king
the concept of free and how that is used
in marketing and that taught me a lot
also i read that book for fun i was not
assigned that book i just read it i also
read a book on advertising by george
ogilvy called ogilvy on advertising that
was also a recreational read
i learned about fonts i learned that
white type against a black background
looks 10 larger among other sort of
useless pieces of information that are
kind of ingrained in my head about why
things work the differences between
non-serif and serif fonts graphic design
so i tended to expand my horizons by
just recreationally reading books that
had nothing to do with my chosen pathway
which was filmmaking
additionally
in terms of my education
i grew up pretty poor
um single mother raised us and i really
wanted to go to usc film school i really
wanted to go to usc
why george lucas went there and george
lucas was my hero because he made star
wars and i want to go to the same school
that george lucas went well my family
being poor it wasn't even an option for
me
and i mean i was disheartened i was
going to this commuter college wayne
state university in detroit
and i was taking their film courses and
recreationally reading books about
marketing and
fonts and
it was i know it sounds strange
but i really want to glean all that
knowledge and and when i was i was just
so disheartened and i remember going on
this kind of life-changing trip to the
west coast
my
mother took my sister and i to go visit
my uncle
who lived in the san diego area and i
begged her i said look i know we're
gonna go to like disneyland and do the
touristy stuff can you just take me to
the campus of of of usc just please take
me to the campus
and we just drove onto campus and i went
to their bookstore
and i took all the money that i had
brought for this trip and i bought a
copy of every book that i could afford
from the film program literally a stack
of books this big going into my suitcase
bought every single book and the books
that i couldn't afford to buy didn't
have enough money for i just wrote down
the name of the book and the author
and i went back to and i read all those
books and i said if i can't afford this
education and if i cannot afford to go
to this school
i'm going to read all the same books as
the as the the the rich kids that are
going to this school i'm just going to
read all the same books
so i'll have that knowledge i took i i
took that list of books and those books
that i had purchased and i typed up a
list and i passed it out to my film
class and i said hey check it out we
were reading some of those books but not
all of them i said this is what the
students at usc
are reading i i feel like like i'm just
going to read all these books and that's
what i did
oddly enough i
dropped out
of school it was really a conflict
between i remember at the time
my parents
debating over who should pay for my
education i was getting some financial
aid but i was working three jobs i still
had paper routes when i was in college
so i worked at a video store
restaurants on the weekends and i had
newspaper routes
and getting financial aid and just
trying to do my best to get through
college and it was
uh
it was a lot so
um i finally just said i can't
i can't continue doing this you know and
i
that's
when i decided i would just do this
thing called film threat
because
i could it would give me an excuse to
talk to filmmakers
because they'd have to talk to me
because i was doing this zine right
and i i ended up
you know months after the first issues
of film threat came out i dropped out of
college
years later
ironically i wrote a book called the
ultimate film festival survival guide
which is now for a lot of film programs
in their in part of their independent
film studies my book is required reading
so i have done speaking engagements at
certain colleges so i just find it funny
that here i am like i dropped out of
college
dropped out of film school
never completed my formal education and
now i talk to students who have read my
book which
is filled with a lot of
no bs advice
about how to
launch your your career in independent
film
when you saw the list of books for usc
at that time when you had visited uh la
did you almost feel like you were being
led in on a secret
in some way wow when i when i when i
looked at the types of books that
that were part of that program
it was kind of like getting a glimpse
into like this secret world because
there was a better balance of
there were some film theory you know and
and
you know critical essay types of books
that got into a philosophy of film and
cinema but then there were more
production books
cinematography right production sound
like much more of the
much more about the craft of filmmaking
so i felt that their choices of books
had a much
better balance
um but i was pleased to see some of the
some of the the
philosophical books mixed in there as
well
um i really think it's like what you're
what you're attracted to i love the
philosophy i also think at the end of
the day you know
um you got you got to know
you got to know how everything functions
and works together you have to know
about editing not just the theory of
editing but how to physically do it so i
so
i i think that and a lot of trade
schools have cropped up where you can
pay
you can pay a sum of money and just get
an education and trade but i feel like
you're never not done with your
education i mean myself even like i'm
always learning something i'm always
listening to you know uh
filmmaker commentary and podcasts and
and and whatnot i'm i'm always i'm
always learning it's like that that
thirst for knowledge has never
it's never left me
would you recommend to
well maybe this is too personal but but
having gone a route that wasn't as
traditional no no you can go too okay i
mean as someone who also dropped out of
school
and it was mostly because of financial
reasons
if i were to have children now i don't
know what i would advise them but i
don't have kids so i don't have to worry
about that but just as a parent what did
you tell
yeah i you know um i really think it's
it's it comes down to a personal choice
i feel like there is a generation that
may have not been given
enough useful
um
education that would apply to what what
the marketplace is looking for
that's why i think you see the rise of
so many independent creators whether it
be on youtube filmmakers and whatnot
there's so much more opportunity for
independent creators but i do think it's
important to have that base knowledge
you know so
i don't know i i i
god it's a it's a tough one one thing i
do know is i never advise friends of
mine who are making films to ever go in
debt i mean i know i know the math i
know that if you borrow thirty thousand
dollars on a credit card and only pay
the minimum
it'll take you over a decade to pay it
off and you'll pay almost a hundred
thousand dollars don't do that
and so student loans not recommended if
there is any way to get around getting
yourself in any sort of debt go that way
so
do i recommend or not recommend a formal
education i feel like that's your
personal choice what i will say is don't
go into debt if there's any way to avoid
debt or manage it or at least know that
if you're going to go into a reasonable
amount of debt that you're able to
afford it you know it's it's it's
something that
is viable not something
you get nor i hear these
to me horror stories from friends that
have gotten themselves in north of 100
000 in debt from their education
and i think this is crazy you know
you'll never build up any sort of
financial security so
that i would recommend avoid debt
but choose your own pathway whether it's
a non-traditional one or a traditional
in terms of your education and never
ever stop learning meaning you always
got a book that you're reading
or commentary that you're listening to i
always this is why i don't mind la
traffic which i know we all sit in a lot
if you live in l.a you're going to be in
traffic i've got a book ready to go
i'm not i don't really because i spend
too much time in front of a screen
most days that i don't tend to read a
book but i'm very well listened so i
will listen to a lot of books and i tend
to go between i love biographies um you
know autobiographies uh written by the
author i and i tend to go from
non-fiction to fiction i just ping pong
between the two
um
and uh yeah i'm a big big audible
fan so
um but yeah like that education should
never be ending you should always be
curious and always be challenging
yourself and if you're not
thinking if you're not thinking and
questioning it's like well that's then
you're just
you know no one's ever done i mean like
devices that we have
they're not done that's why that's where
firmware upgrade updates come from right
so i consider my continuing education to
be
firmware updates to my brain i know
that's a weird way of putting it someone
out there who's watching or listening to
this is going to understand it but
i feel my continuing education is just a
series of firmware updates
you